[Musique]
thomassin est malone apex est un jeu
très simple il ya des chasseurs
vous êtes la croix vous aurez une avance
de trois heures
tomasz c'est la fin de la route
pour moi je fais confortable
tout metz malone est peut-être la plus
grande croix que vous n'affrontez jamais
lui est ce qu'on sera remboursé si on
cultive pour moins d'une heure
c'est un ex flic accusé de meurtre
pendant un cambriolage qui a mal tourné
malone a défié la mort plus de fois que
la plupart des commandos marine
en d'autres termes
l'univers ne semble pas pouvoir les mini
t'es bon gamin je suis plus que bon je
suis le bacon lse du dimanche matin
vous constaterez
mam s'est fait bander c'est ça et qu'est
ce que ça leur rapporte qu'est-ce qui se
passe l'étude touche gagnée et je vous
garanti la liberté
rappelons à malone qui est le chasseur
qui est la proie
un
homme comme lui n'aurait jamais dû venir
dans un endroit comme celui-ci
attention forcément la tête de thomas
solange
alors ça fait quoi d'être chassés